bom eu queria saber daqui quem tem tesão
por algo ou por alguém
ainda bem algumas pessoas têm mas eu
queria saber quem tem r$1 teseu pelas
coisas pelo corpo pela materialidade dos
objetos não é bom hoje eu queria falar
pra vocês de uma galera que tem esse
tesão pelas coisas têm bastante desejo
em fazer e enfim tem um super prazer em
desenvolver as coisas né durante o
processo
então falar hoje do movimento maker e
sua relação entre com a sexualidade e
com a própria vida
a gente vai pensar a sexualidade ela é
uma reprodução é o que dá uma
continuidade para a própria vida e bom
pensando no início é esse
esse processo de fazer nada mais é do
que a gente disse que só lhe dizendo que
o exercício com esses objetos e fazendo
ele se reproduzirem fazerem com que eles
aconteçam quase uma reprodutibilidade da
própria vida sem pensar que no brasil o
movimento maker ele ainda é bastante
inicial
apesar disso a gente tem no sangue nas
nossas veias é todo brasileiro tem essa
cultura da gambiarra e que enfim é
exatamente fazer muito com muito pouco é
contudo que a gente tem disponível e
diante de todas as adversidades é dar um
jeito e fazer ea idéia é esse fazer ele
sempre está em picado e muita
responsabilidade afinal o homem ele é
próprio ele que é tem as condições
materiais para produzir as coisas né
produzir seu próprio cotidiano e aí essa
produção ela foi feita com mais prazer é
isso pode ser muito mais interessante
para a nossa vida
esse prazer dessa troca de picar o nosso
corpo objeto é muito interessante ea
partir de se fazer é com esse prazer é
que a gente consegue salton isótopo
matizar o nosso cotidiano
ao nosso cotidiano ele está meio crise
enfim a gente basicamente trabalha e
trabalha pra conseguir dinheiro
esse dinheiro a gente usa pra consumir
as coisas e geralmente esse é consumir
as coisas ou pagar contas né
e geralmente todas essas coisas que a
gente consome foram pensadas e
projetadas por outras pessoas não pela
gente então a nossa necessidade ou enfim
essas necessidades criadas
ora são criadas ou elas não são
realmente alcançadas e aí como é que a
gente quebra e se esse ciclo é esse
ciclo vicioso é bom isso é esse
cotidiano né produtivista que a gente
tem essa de sempre tá né produzindo
coisas o tempo todo a gente vai pensar
produzir as coisas com responsabilidade
é um processo que demanda tempo demanda
a consciência dos processos entender a
origem as origens das coisas entender
como tudo é feito e aí esse tempo é é um
tempo que geralmente a gente não tem
para se dedicar porque a gente tá nesse
cotidiano trabalhando e tendo que está
contando a própria vida e eu costumo
dizer que o movimento maker
ele é um movimento materialista
eu costumo chamar de ativismo
materialista afinal os meios de produção
ao invés de estarem na mão de algumas
pessoas
eles agora ser um domésticos ea gente
consegue produzir dentro das próprias
casas
além disso quando a gente pensar em
hardware né a gente enfim se coloca
nesses objetos e é um processo bastante
interessante
bom então eu vou contar um pouco pra
vocês como eu cheguei nesse movimento
maker
quando era criança era muito desastrada
porque na real eu sou quase cega e
enxergam muito muito muito mal então eu
tava sempre caindo principalmente quando
tinha a porta de vidro tipo sempre dava
com a cara e aí é por não enxergar muito
bem as coisas e eu acabava sempre
destruindo quase tudo
é quando tentava ligar ou fazer alguma
coisa eu geralmente estragava esses
objetos e aí bom meus pais eles sempre
boa agora que você estragou
você tem que dar um jeito de enfim
arrumar essas coisas é foi aí que
ofereça esse ato é de ressignificar as
coisas de consertar virou praticamente
um estilo de vida e meio que é assim que
eu vivo até hoje porque afinal os
objetos eles não precisam ter um fim
quando eles quebram a gente pode
resignar ficar isso é entender que esses
objetos eles podem ter essa circular
idade né que nem sempre esse fim é
quando eles não funcionam mais a gente
pode realmente hackear que significa e
aí hoje em dia enfim eu já faz um tempo
e descobrir esse conceito que na cultura
japonesa chama quem julgue que é
exatamente como que a gente conserta
reparar as coisas quebradas e
ressignifica esses objetos
lógico que nessa técnica eles surjam
tipo cola de ouro eu não fazia isso mas
de qualquer forma eu estava sempre
fazendo o néné ressignificado e reparei
desses objetos que eu tava quebrando
principalmente quando eram como é coisas
eletrônicas eu dava um jeito de entender
como aqueles componentes eles atuavam
dentro dos objetos para conseguir
simplesmente consertar
outra coisa que me levou pra esse
movimento foi essa questão da autonomia
cidade com que a gente cria autonomia
para desenvolver pra pensar pra que
significa e criar as coisas
bom eu fiz na verdade antes de mesmo de
me formar
eu passei por cinco cursos diferentes
enfim dá pra perceber que eu sou
realmente uma pessoa bem perdida mas é
mas se perder é importante também para
se encontrar
de qualquer forma enfim até encontrar um
curso que pudesse enfim dá conta de
algumas coisas que eu achava
interessante eu andei bastante e aí na
verdade eu finalizei o único curso que
era possível
de fato eu finalizar quero um curso
que ensinava a coisa mais básica para a
nossa vida que é o desenvolvimento de
projetos
afinal se a gente for pensar a vida é um
grande projeto que a gente pode patinar
em projetos menores
então por exemplo se eu vou fazer uma
viagem eu posso projetar essa viagem
fazer o roteiro saber exatamente quando
ou onde eu vou passar
enfim passar vou fazer uma faxina posso
programar a ela para que ela seja enfim
muito mais rápida
assim como se eu quiser fazer uma
faculdade terminais também faz parte de
um projeto de vida
então esse essa metodologia de
desenvolvimento de projeto foi a coisa
mais importante que eu aprendi na
faculdade e aí diante disso nessa bendo
desenvolver projetos e em qualquer
escala não interessa se ela é uma do
queijo de dna ou seja trabalhar e
escalas nanométricas como também na
escala urbana e desenvolver um projeto
de planejamento urbano
não interessa qual a escala eu
conseguiria desenvolver esses projetos e
foi isso que a faculdade de arquitetura
e urbanismo me ensinou de mais
importante se a gente for pensar a
projetar é criar e produzir e dar
sentido às coisas e como que a gente
passa a produzir a criar coisas que
realmente façam sentido não só para a
gente mas também para a sociedade que a
gente vive e também sim né detonar o
meio ambiente
e aí vou pensar essa diferença entre o
movimento maker o movimento hacker por
exemplo os atores eles geralmente dão
conta de saber como os sistemas e as
coisas funcionam na sua profundidade
para conseguir que significa diz
funciona diz funcionalizar fazer alguma
outra coisa com aquilo que a gente vai
pensar o movimento um hacker ele age no
que sai dado diferente do maker que ele
produz e cria coisas diferentes sempre
ele realmente coloca as coisas no mundo
o seu desejo e aí ele age no que não
está dado
e aí eu gosto muito dessa frase do cauã
dessa a gente vai pensar a arte é uma
dessas coisas que enfim não está dada e
que a gente cria então o homem ele enfim
escala montanha porque ela tá lá a gente
faz arte porque ela não está
eu acho que é isso que a gente cria
novos sentidos e significados para a
nossa própria existência
e aí a partir dessa autonomia é de como
a gente sabe buscar o conhecimento isso
é uma das coisas mais importantes porque
para desenvolver esses projetos em
diferentes áreas
eu preciso saber enfim como buscar esse
conhecimento
então esse desenvolvimento de vida
orientada esses projetos
ele acaba fazendo muito sentido
principalmente quando a gente fala de
educação ea entender que nesses
processos e rat também é bastante
importante né entender que enfim as
coisas elas não são um problema mas se
há coisas a serem resolvidas na desafios
como por exemplo aqui na frente de vocês
falando pra mim é um grande desafio
posso estar errando errando muito mas é
assim que a gente acaba aprendendo e
poder falhar também uma coisa importante
nesse processo e aí o terceiro ponto que
também me fez encontrar esse movimento
maker enfim essa coisa de se colocar com
o corpo de ir para a materialidade das
coisas
afinal a única coisa que a gente tem de
fato que a gente possui nessa vida é o
nosso corpo e essa fisicalidade é
bastante importante e se colocar na
matéria é muito importante para também
entender a origem das coisas é respeitar
o processo é também criar relações
afetivas com tudo que está sendo
desenvolvido e aí esse desenvolvimento
esse processo ele acaba sendo muito mais
importante do que o objeto final
então esse processo que tem bastante
prazer é que ele é gostoso porque a
gente quer desenvolver uma coisa que vem
de um desejo anterior
ele cria esse fetiche do projeto do
processo muito mais do que o fetiche da
mercadoria final em si isso essa
experiência é muito mais importante e aí
a gente for pensar esse sex appeal do
processo né e também dos objetos é essa
do aceu que a gente faz
ele também é também é uma coisa que
enfim trás pra frente do movimento maker
a gente entende que o nosso corpo que
essa coisa que a gente possui é um corpo
político e
exatamente a partir dessa consciência de
como a gente produz as coisas é que faz
com que a política encontre a
sexualidade e essas coisas elas acabam
se permeando a gente for pensar
desconstrução do do cotidiano execute
di'anno automatizado que a gente tem que
dar conta em fim das coisas básicas sem
a gente consegui entender os processos
enfim a fundo ele também faz com que a
gente perca um pouco a crítica e quando
a gente fala do movimento maker que é um
movimento político é que a gente faz
repensar as nossas formas de consumir
dia e produzir de consumir de aprender
inclusive se relacionar com as coisas
afinal quando a gente faz algo a gente
passa a dar muito mais importância
aquilo é diferente de quando a gente
compra e se fazer crítico ele é bastante
importante é entender que as tecnologias
não interessa se elas são digitais
químicas analógicas biológicas
elas são ferramentas que devem que devem
ser apropriadas e disseminados e
democratizados mas ok é como fazer parte
desse movimento e de tudo isso em são
paulo como vocês viram tem a maior rede
de laboratórios de fabricação digital
públicas do mundo é única experiência de
trazer todas essas questões o movimento
maker como uma política pública é aí que
o cidadão ele encontra todas essas
tecnologias democratizados e consegue
sim mudar o seu cotidiano mudar sua
forma de vida e essa mudança é muito
importante porque é esse potencial que o
movimento maker trás
é o que realmente vai trazer mudanças
efetivas e essas mudanças elas não
ocorrem sozinhas não é apenas eu
produzindo sozinha é o famoso do it
yourself mas o due to gueder como que a
gente pode aprender e colaborar
afinal quando a gente faz sozinho a
gente vai mais rápido mas quando a gente
faz junto a gente vai muito mais longe
então por isso eu gosto de dizer que o
vira uma metáfora bill semiótica para
tempos de crise é gente
alguém sabe o que é que fica aqui não
não não sinta ok é porque eu gosto tanto
do prefiro eu piro
nessa essas bolinhas porque o kefir ele
é uma simbiose genes e absolutamente
incrível com mais de 25 micro organismos
de espécies diferentes então desde o
reino maneira então têm bactérias têm
leveduras e tem protozoários do agente
tem três reinos inclusive nem é isso que
os últimos paper já disseram é essa
esses microrganismos eles convivem muito
bem
se uma dessas espécies aí puxa acabou já
era não tem mais reproduz eu é fim o
kefir passa a não existir
isso mostra o quanto que a gente tem a
aprender com esses microorganismos que
na verdade a coe volos eu ela faz muito
mais sentido que a competição
e daí se a gente for pensar o que enfim
o que seria zerar na vida digamos é
pessoas dizem que é fazer um filho
plantar uma árvore escrever um livro mas
de fato eu pergunto pra vocês e que
vocês querem deixar no mundo que vocês
querem colocar e criar nele eu acho que
assim a partir de qual o seu desejo real
que realmente te dá teseu a gente vai
conseguir entender esses processos e
buscar mais prazer na nossa vida
obrigada
[Aplausos]